This episode was proudly made possible by
the all-new 2015 Subaru Legacy.
It's not just a sedan, it's a Subaru.
The appendix is one of the human body’s
greatest mysteries, but did you know it actually
does serve a purpose?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and as usual,
everything we know about the human body is
wrong.
We’ve been taught for generations now that
the appendix is completely useless, with many
textbooks suggesting that it’s nothing more
than a vestigial organ - something that used
to serve a purpose, but is now redundant.
But it turns out that’s only partially true.
And a study out of Duke University, found
that while it’s not necessary for survival,
the appendix actually does serve a function
- essentially, it’s a safehouse for good
bacteria.
The idea here is that certain diseases, like
cholera - an infection of the small intestine
caused by contaminated water - and dysentery,
an infection that causes bloody diarrhea - can
wipe out all of the bacteria that our guts
need for digestion.
And when that happens, the appendix steps
in and basically “reboots” the digestive
system, by replenishing all the good bacteria.
Now obviously, people living in developed
countries don’t have to worry much about
those kinds of infections - which is why we’re
perfectly capable of living without an appendix.
But it does make you wonder - why humans still
get appendicitis, if that organ never really
gets used?
And it turns out, it’s similar to the reason
we get allergies.
By living in a modern hygienic society, we’re
rarely ever exposed to dangerous pathogens
or parasites - so when our immune system finally
DOES get challenged, it overreacts.
It’s called the “hygiene hypothesis”
- and in the case of your appendix, an overreactive
immune system can lead to obstruction of the
intestines, that in turn, leads to appendicitis.
So when you think about it, the reason your
appendix never gets used - modern hygiene
- is also the reason it gets inflamed.
And as someone who’s had their appendix
removed, I can say that the pain of living
with an inflamed one, is a lot of more severe
than the consequences of living without it.
So don’t feel bad at all about having it
removed.
As far as I’m concerned, good riddance!
What about you guys though?
Have you had your appendix taken out?
And how awesome were those scars?
Leave your responses in the comments below
- and as always, thank you guys for watching!